[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo avance
informativo aquí en las 24 yo soy
liliana valencia iniciamos en eeuu donde
los equipos de emergencia trabajan
contrareloj e intentando rescatar
personas que puedan estar atrapadas bajo
los escombros del edificio residencial
de 12 pisos que se desplomó parcialmente
en la madrugada del pasado jueves en
sort sites cerca de miami
autoridades locales confirmaron que
hasta el momento se encontraron cuatro
cuerpos sin vida mientras que 159
personas permanecen desaparecidas más de
20 de ellas de origen latinoamericano
entre las cuales hay 9 argentinos la
cifra de muertos podría aumentar con el
paso de las horas
la justicia de minnesota también en eeuu
condenó a 22 años y medio de cárcel al
ex policía de minneapolis a derek joven
acusado de asesinar al afroamericano
georg floyd el 25 de mayo de 2020
joven debería pasar 15 años en prisión y
siete y medio en detención domiciliaria
además le descontaron de la sentencia
los 199 días que duró el juicio tras el
cual fue declarado culpable de tres
cargos de homicidio los abogados del ex
agente tienen 90 días para apelar la
sentencia
la familia de floyd dijo que el castigo
era apenas un 'tirón de orejas' de esta
sentencia de 22 años que le dieron a
este hombre es un tirón de orejas
estamos cumpliendo sentencias de por
vida porque no le tenemos más en
nuestras vidas y eso me duele mucho y
viendo a su hija la hermosa llana
diciendo que el vídeo de su padre cambió
el mundo él cambió el mundo pero al
final le dan un tirón de orejas
en noticias del coi 19 de honduras
recibirá este domingo un millón y medio
de dosis de la vacuna de moderna contra
el cob y 19 donadas por estados unidos a
través del mecanismo kóvacs de la ms
el envío hace parte de los 80 millones
de vacunas que el presidente joe biden
prometió compartir con otros países
también brasil el segundo país más
afectado por el coi 19 a nivel mundial
recibió 2 millones de dosis de la vacuna
de johnson y johnson donadas por el
gobierno by den a dosis llegaron este
viernes al aeropuerto de sao paulo
y continuamos hablando del coi 19 porque
5 países de américa latina están entre
las naciones con mayor mortalidad del
mundo por cada 100.000 habitantes
perú lidera la trágica lista con 587
puntos 73 muertes de la mayor tasa de
mortalidad por cada 100.000 habitantes
del mundo seguido de brasil con 240 y
124 y colombia que alcanzó los 203 89
luego argentina con 200 3,47 y por
último méxico con 180 y 1,91 muertos por
cada 100.000 habitantes levemente
superado por eeuu
paraguay chile y bolivia están también
entre las primeras 10 naciones más
afectadas esto según cifras de la
universidad johns hopkins
entretanto haití es hasta ahora el único
país de la región donde ningún ciudadano
ha sido vacunado contra el coronavirus
al tiempo que las autoridades declararon
el estado de emergencia sanitaria ante
el repunte de los contagios con una
población de más de 11 millones de
habitantes y un sistema de salud
precario haití es uno de los pocos
países a nivel mundial donde no han
llegado vacunas esto después de que el
gobierno se negara a recibir dosis de
alta técnica por medio del mecanismo
kóvacs
en contraste españa vive hoy su primer
día sin tapabocas obligatorio y
exteriores después de más de un año de
obligatoriedad de la medida para
contener el coronavirus sin embargo una
buena parte de los ciudadanos ha
preferido mantener el uso de las
mascarillas como una forma de prevenir
nuevos contagios más de la mitad de la
población ha recibido al menos una dosis
de la vacuna así finalizamos continuar
en las 24 punto com